keith moon he was so out of control he
was maddening
a lot of the time right and a lot of the
stuff that he did that people laugh
about they think oh that was really
funny
yeah when you there at the time it some
of it wasn't funny at all
right because when you're in a session
and you're trying to get something but
he was such a wonderful kid he was such
an enormous character
yeah he every facet of his personality
was way out there you know he was the he
was the most
loving he could be the most hurtful
respectful most caring
you know it's all completely like
fireworks like what do you think was
behind all the drinking and
what was behind all the smashing of like
the hotel rooms and all that stuff
what do you think that anger was i my
own opinion i think he was slightly
autistic
yeah um and they didn't know how to
diagnose that stuff
and he obviously had a you know an
addictive personality
right i've never known anyone take the
amount of booze drugs that mooney did
you know remember black bombers and all
that stuff from the 60s
you know people would take one and they
would be higher as a kite for a day
he would take a handful and he would
literally
what would black bombers like speed and
all that kind of stuff
down there's operations too
drinking with it how many people have
that kind of constitution
well the person that used to hold the
record uh for that was a guy called
ollie reed remember oliver reed
him and moon became buddies when we did
tommy he played the the father
the stepfather and uh oliver had the
kind of
legendary name for being the drinker
right right you out-drink richard harris
richard burton
he could put them all under the table
right right until moon came along
okay he he taught them all along he took
the title so
the moon challenged ollie to a drinking
contest and oliver reed used to live in
this great big monastery
converted monastery in surrey and he had
a pub at the end of the drive
right very useful
[Laughter]
so he challenged him to a drinking
contest and they went and they they got
two
they got a bottle of brownie each and
apparently it was went down to about the
third bottle of brandy each oh my god
and and and uh oliver he passed out
under the table
moon stood up and said [ __ ] you ollie
i'm going to the pub for a real drink
to his pub because moon had a pub at the
end of his drive
that's crazy you know you're laughing it
down but like did you ever
sit him down or did the band ever sit
him down and try and do what they call
an intervention nowadays and try and get
him help or was it just something that
just wasn't thought of back then because
everyone was so young and carefree we
didn't know
we didn't know what we were doing i mean
we talked to him we tried everything you
know i
i've got lots of you know memories of
going to see him sitting in
sitting in bed recovering from some
one the memorable one was when he took a
a monkey tranquilizer oh my god in san
francisco [ __ ] is a monkey tranquilizer
i don't know
whatever they give the monkeys to calm
them down or a rhino
tranquilizer or whatever it was whatever
and and he
he he literally passed out second song
on stage bang
and he was out for 24 hours and as this
drug left him it kind of
the next day we had to push him around
in the wheelchair because his legs
wouldn't work
but this bit was working right his mouth
worked
yeah this bit was working right uh so we
could give him some stick while we were
pushing him in the wheelchair
and then we got into new york and he
laid him babies and uh
it was it was very very and he but he
was sincerely
really he used to destroy him when he
did it you know he would
he would really be upset that he'd let
us down yeah
would be incredibly unhappy and would
pete as a songwriter get a pissed off at
him because like you know it's important
to
pete i'm sure that his songs be played
the exact certain way
and and i would imagine he'd get it oh
he liked the fire i mean that didn't
matter too much but
we used to get pissed at him because we
cared about him and we
we could see the inevitability of what
was going to happen
but he seemed to have nine lives i mean
he did things that
i've seen keith moon you know the the
air conditioners
you don't see so many of them now that
go through the window yeah you see him
dancing on one of those 16 stories
in the air brandy so he had a death wish
right now he was just fearless he's one
of those kind of
people just had no fear of anything do
you understand that at all i mean that
is
crazy it's not i mean when the first the
first days of um
airport security were you know when the
palestinian thing was going on in the
70s
and they brought you know very early
airport security
moon they used to have a kind of a
curtain thing that you went in and they
just they pat you down you down
yeah huge queues built up to go into
these things moon just
stood naked in the airplane completely
down to his underpants
before he got there and before he went
in in front of the whole airport
off came the underpants he just didn't
care
you